Well,
how are you? Cristian Cásseres greets you with
his informative arm of News Now in
Spanish. Two people in Las Vegas have
been arrested in connection with the takeover
of the Capitol a few weeks ago. These
two arrests in the Valley are the most
recent of the 130 arrested that
They have already been carried out throughout the country
accused of participating along with hundreds
of protesters who
violently attacked the US Capitol
on January 6. The operation in Las
Vegas was carried out by
federal agents and the Metro police. Our
team of investigators tracking
legal documents and discovered the
identity of one of the arrested
investigators identified a new
team crate from las vegas who appears in
these images with a red
white and blue bandana and equipped with
military tools among the
documents it is known that it was an
anonymous tip that  helped investigators
gather more evidence against tecos
bueno beneficiaries of the daca program
are in  france 2 of a possible change
in their immigration status after a
recent tweet the president of the usa
show park in recently published that
the trimmers are americans and i want them
to remember that they have an ally in me
within the white house so take
immediate action  to strengthen daca the
president immediately protected the
federal program through an
executive order during his first day as
president in which he promised to protect
the more than 64,000 young immigrants
who are in danger of being deported
the nevada local organization
affirms that there are more  of 14,000
beneficiaries of the program in the state
of nevada and efforts continue to
raise awareness in the community for the
state of nevada is surpassing the
vaccination effort against cob and
19 according to a bloomberg analysis
shows that nevada is
placed in the number  47 among other
states this is an increase from the 50th place
we were at at the beginning
of the  week plus
6.3 percent of all residents
of nevada have already received their first
vaccine but we are still below the
national level
good one of the reasons why
the distribution of the vaccine
against cob and 19 has been slow is the lack of
reserves  From the federal government
our team of investigators
discovered that Clark County is
scheduled to receive 42 doses per
week in addition to revealing that the county
can administer 92,000 vaccines per
week at that rate
all Clark County residents could be vaccinated
Even with the first dose in 20 weeks,
but the more doses of vaccines arrive in
the valley, the time to vaccinate
residents will decrease and the Golden
Knights rescheduled the game against
San Luis due to the coronavirus. The National League
left here notice that the player
Álex Pepper  ice cream together with a member of
the coaching team were under the
protocols of the coronavirus the announcement
was made 10 days after it was revealed  that
all coaches were under self-
quarantine for now the
training facility has been closed and
all team scheduled games are being updated
finally we
take a look at temperatures
an atmospheric system continues to ravage
across california
creating snow and rain  In that region, the
same system that will bring light rain
for us and snow for the mountains,
the temperatures will continue to be cold and
tonight they will drop to 50.